BRET HAS A SPECIAL INTERVIEW.
GOOD EVENING.
I AM BRET BAIER IN WASHINGTON.
PEOPLE HERE IN THE NATION'S
CAPITOL AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY
GET TO SEE THE JUST DECLASSIFIED
MEMO ALLEGES FBI ABUSES IN
SURVEILLANCE PRACTICES.
WE HAVE COMPLETE REPORTING AND
REACTION.
AND A LIVE EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH DEVIN NUNES
.
THE MAN WHO PUT TOGETHER THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED THE
FINDINGS IN THIS MEMO A
DISGRACE.
FELLOW REPUBLICANS SAY IT SHOWS
HIGH LEVEL POLITIZATION OF THE
OUT OF CONTEXT.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH CATHERINE.
FIRST TO GET EXERPTS OF THE
MEMO.
>> THANKS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SENT A LETTER TO
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CONFIRMING THE PRESIDENT USED
HIS AUTHORITY AS COMMANDER AND
THE MEMO PAINTS A TROUBLING
PICTURE.
THE 4-PAGE REPUBLICAN STAFF MEMO
MAKES THE CASE THAT THE SECRET
NATIONAL SECURITY COURT WAS KEPT
IN THE DARK BY THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHEN THEY
PAGE.
THE COURT WAS NEVER TOLD THE
FORMER BRITISH SPY WAS PAID BY
DEMOCRATS TO PUT TOGETHER THE
TRUMP DOSSIER.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE ADMITED TO
BRUCE OHR HIS FEELINGS AGAINST
CANDIDATE AND SAID, QUOTE:
OHR WAS DEMOTED OVER HIS
CONTACTS WITH STEELE AND SIMPSON
WHOSE OPPOSITION RESEARCH FUN
FUSION GPS DIRECTED THE TRUMP
PROJECT.
BANK RECORDS SHOW OHR'S WIFE
WORKED FOR FUSION GPS AND BEGAN
INVESTIGATING TRUMP IN MAY 2016.
REPUBLICAN INVESTIGATORS SAID
THE COURT WAS NEVER TOLD ABOUT
APPLICATION NOR RENEWALS
DISCLOSED THE ROLE OF THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN IN FUNDING
STEELE'S EFFORT BUT THEY WERE
KNOWN.
THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE THAT NO SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT WOULD HAVE BEEN SOUGHT
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER INFORMATION.
STEELE WAS DIRECTED TO BRIEF A
THE CARTER PAGE FISA APPLICATION
CITED A YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE WHICH
FOCUSES ON PAGE'S JULY TRIP TO
MOSCOW.
PAGE DENIED WORKING WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
>> I HAVE NEVER BROKEN ANY LAW
IN RUSSIA OR RELATING TO ANY
RUSSIAN PERSON.
>> ACCORDING TO THE MEMO, AN FBI
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE CHIEF SAID
SALICIOUS BUT IT WAS USED TO
RENEW THE SURVEILLANCE OF PAGE
BY COMEY, McCABE AND OBAMA
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND LATER BY
THE TRUMP APPOINTEE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
>> THE REPUBLICANS RAISED THE
SPECTER OF LEGALITY MADE TO THE